i have about three  fillings that have fallen out which were  from nhs like years ago  um i have a wisdom tooth which is  growing into my cheek but the other side  of my mouth i have  a tooth that is missing and a big  feeling that's missing missing that  needs filling in i tried to get an  appointment with a local nhs dentist  but because the pandemic had just hit  they were all closed i tried to find  another nhs dentist but i just wasn't  able to i actually had an overdose of  painkillers because  the tooth pain was so bad eventually i  caved and paid for a private checkup but  once she gave me the treatment plan i  burst into tears and ended up having a  panic attack in the seat because it's  just so expensive just hoping and  praying that one day i get an amazing  promotion or something and i can afford  suddenly afford it but apart from that  my only hope is that i can get an nhs  dentist